already have our first super chat in the
house from the internet i never forget
thank you so much for the super chat
okay so
today's topic yes are you guys aware of
what happened with kim kardashian's son
yeah sure yeah yeah that was a good
tragedy yeah
crazy ones though so for for the viewers
that may or may not know
okay
kim kardashian has like a four ish year
old son and he was playing roblox and um
somebody mentioned his mother's
sex tape on roblox
so um
the kids have no idea that kim got
famous through a sex tape
yeah i think that's a bit that's a bit
of a hard conversation to have with your
son to think you know that's what i did
before and it's coming up now how many
years later so it was a bit pink um so
so right now i want to give the men
the chance to speak
so what would you guys
date someone like kim kardashian that
has had
that has had um a sex tape on the
internet i think we can all agree on
this i think we all wouldn't yeah
probably date but whether it's a
marriage you know yeah
respectfully humbly
can't be having a wife back
on the sex tape
this on your passes your past and it
reading the future is different don't
yeah that no no comment yeah but clearly
that means it comes up
i mean yeah but
[ __ ]
um
i mean yeah it would but i don't know
like that was your past in it like i
guess for some people you have to do
what you do to make one unit so i mean
if you change yes yeah but men have to
like get a job
like you can make money in other ways
you can go work at mcdonald's
it's just it's just they want fast money
it's not
like if that happens to a dude he's just
homeless
oh
oh damn
drink to that drink
well
so so you would date a girl that had
like a sex tape like that
okay
i'll be all like we're saying this now
but that this game came out we would we
would
you would we would but would you marry
would you date that's the question
marina's there i feel like i don't know
let's say you're talking and then later
on like later on like you find that oh
that's what she did
like i don't know that's the question
because like
would it be easier for you to like leave
or would you actually stay like that's
where the problem is
i mean kim k you know everything about
her already so you going to marry her
like you you know everything she's done
but with another girl i mean
i'm not gonna lie i probably would i
probably would you probably still would
yeah
why like why wouldn't she pick a girl
that like doesn't have that like if
there was a girl i didn't have the oh of
course yeah but if that's the girl that
i've met then that you like
yeah because it's just interesting to me
because kanye could have anyone he's a
billionaire like why is he picking a
girl that's for the streets
she's made so much money though so
either way she's actually an independent
woman regardless of what she's that's
why the wi-fi but then again
yeah but then again
that kind of stuff is a bit of a wild
yeah but i mean
do you mention do you guys care about a
girl's money
no
well not at this point but it's nice if
you have money in it yeah it's not just
don't be flashing in my face and saying
i don't need you i don't do this i don't
is a woman's ceo like hot to you
yeah yeah
really
yeah independent really
because
i've always heard from guys that they
don't care about a girl's money so it's
interesting that you guys have the
opposite point of view it just depends
on the situation uh-huh so for example
like
if i'm older and i'm trying to get my
stuff together
and
she hasn't like for example isn't has
been really ambitious
then why would i like go for her because
it's not really in like i'm not going to
elevate myself to a different point in
life
with her but she's not really she
doesn't have money she's not like
ambitious no points
so what do you think would you date a
guy that had a sex tape
um
would i
[Music]
i mean
if it's not something he's trying to do
again
like on a regular then yeah i think i
would really yeah oh my god depends
though it really it really does depend
is it leaked
is it something you're doing every year
nowadays like people are just recording
themselves like it's normal like that's
what i'm saying like it's normal
like guys are just being
yeah
means
yeah but like you don't think it's kind
of on the girl to vet the guys she
sleeps with and does that with like
doesn't that kind of say something about
her decision-making abilities
i mean it depends on the situation again
because if it's like a past thing and
it's not going to be
every week or he's going out to do that
or i'm seeing it somewhere else or my
friend's sending it to me then yeah yeah
it's a bit different but if he made
money and income because of right how
kim kaden then
i don't know
okay so now the other question do you
guys think that someone's past matters
to an extent yes
yes yes
okay obviously it does the reason i say
it does is because
you can enjoy your young ages but don't
destroy it yeah like yeah you can have
fun and do whatever like
but if you just go and be loose and just
do everything like it's gonna
[Music]
some girls that have bc's that are older
than their age so it's like by the time
they get into that stage where they want
to like settle down because you've been
around it's like no one's going to take
you seriously yeah maybe one guy will
it'll be very hard should you guys there
may be one
ah there's always hope for everyone in
it but you know like maybe one guy like
well but it's like even if now like you
marry that girl imagine walking down the
road oh yeah like she slopped me off in
the block oh yeah she did
that's something that's not for you
no but that's something you're gonna
have to live with like for the rest of
your life you get it yeah and
like even if you marry her yeah it's
like cool you have to go through all
this time to marry the girl it took me
what two weeks just to get slops you get
it so it's like
well it's kind of like she gave
something
to that guy for free and she's making
you like pay for it yeah
gg i'm trying to see
if you've got to pick the right person
for you man
whatever you're ready to deal with
yeah i mean if two jbags meet then it
can be together in it
yeah because they both know what they're
on that's crazy yeah no i would say
though i would say you like what you
like so
if there's a girl that you really like
but a past is crazy
that's not really going to matter too
tough because
you liking her factors more than what
she's done with other people before i
think it depends on like what happens
between when you start speaking to her i
mean yeah and then moving onwards
if it's if it's still wild then
you go through that jesus christ sorry
guys
do you guys do you guys ask girls that
you're saying like about what they've
done before or do you just you're like
see no either evil hear no evil like i
don't want to know really i think i
think when you're when you're going to
speak to a girl
someone knows something do you have
means you don't really even have to ask
directly
you can kind of get
a sense of who someone is
about the way they speak and where they
talk in a way that